welcome to this video the Prince game
again shoe shanghai zoo shanghai
probably not perfectly pronounced but it
does not seem totally off okay you have
the name zone and i'm going for the hook
the variation if possible okay but he
goes night each way I yep I play c6 or
ruki aid I like both moves let's go see
six flexible that still allows me to
choose the central formation that's
slightly uncommon that you want to kenai
g3 here but ok i will play d 5 anyway
now he takes mmm interesting yeah I
wonder if seat XD is an idea or taking
taking with the night even that's very
uncommon but might be might be an idea
now it's um looks rather rather ok why
not something different yeah yeah I
thought maybe c5 mind could be an idea
just just for something different 95
Bishop tutu 22-25 should be ok I think
check yeah if he takes yeah of course
you can do that the question is what am
i doing now just greet a exam probably
keep it simple he gains the temple with
Roxy born but Quinn b6 I don't see any
particular problem Queen B 6 root d 896
should be about equal disposition okay
um now no reason to spend long time him
nice he's slightly more active but still
it looks it looks really solid i will go
to be seven with the Queen okay so what
is this i DM wants to go to h5 on
something like that yeah okay I really
don't see any any big issue I will drop
back to e7 Bishop 38 and then double on
the D file
yes night on g3 is not doing very much
Queen h5 those kind of moves I really
just go on g6 weakens the dark squares
but he has no pieces to use them ok so
just to be a Don is there anything
better 95 is also an option then Bishop
c6 why not try to be a bit more more
active and Bishop c6 Bishop should be
should be well placed here on the
possible night c5 i have ninety-seven if
i want ok and form hmm didn't really
think about that look very much but
maybe I'm wrong in not looking at it I
thought I get to get to have six here to
to fight against the night only form now
it should be ok my position is really
solid um is it going a form like Knight
f6 you form possible
grab it still
before I can go in five as one
possibility and John if I just go if
five
you five rupee for that you can go to at
five but i'm not sure i don't see that
this threatens very much so let's do
that the same time it's not clear maybe
a special can go to hm we are that's
possible
I am a manager blockade on only 5 i'm
certainly in very good shape getting a
piece 25 i also had I think rook deform
as a possible move hmm yeah okay fatigue
now I wonder should I go g6 just not not
clear ok I might do that I have a little
time just to prevent the night coming to
f5 it weakens f6 of course but my
position looks sufficient sufficiently
stable k cover cover the noid yeah if I
manage to trade rook CIO something like
that I'm better even because of my
better pawn structure not sure that this
is going to happen though this is
covering the night from the site and
prepare swoop to aid with doubling PR
interesting maybe maybe with the earth
porn
yeah I don't know I need to be need to
be quick this gives further protection
to the night possibly with roo gave aid
and maybe i can just play rook evade
black back and then then trade on the f
file yeah I don't see what it's got
anything maybe Queen III
Rick property 897 is not play hi morning
he has got his God he's got this um
Ruger 7 that sets you but then this was
a very very stupid idea okay yeah not
happy move giving giving up the stable
position of the bishop
should be five year was was a potential
problem here and Roxy seven is a problem
yeah I really have no move Bishop b5 is
coming wow I have totally misplayed that
I told you miss play lad resins starting
starting from from here it is Sir it's
interesting um it is really interesting
because the position is not really clear
to me it's got this activity but it's a
position that from structural point of
view is this okay for black if I just
get rooks off I'm instantly better the
question is if I were able to do that
maybe am the key is totally different
now okay now I say the computer is
giving age five that black is clearly
better this is the point undermining the
eform the e4 pawn I didn't think about
the move because it weakens the King so
much but maybe it's not mattering yeah
one problem is that h3h frys has no
tests no square so maybe this was the
problem yeah and this was a stupid idea
i was thinking i can go here and then
trade of rooks on the effort but he
always has look f7 of course oh this is
stupid I cannot get get a trade going h5
was really the way to play it this was
then a mistake yeah this is this is very
interesting here if I've is debatable
definitely
but maybe I should take I was under I
was really not thinking so much about f5
I didn't expect this move this is this
is all quite quite logical I know g5 is
also good for black yeah okay I missed a
couple of interesting moments but still
I mean okay this is what's this was
definitely stupid around yet it gets
difficult at least I'm in a practical
game Brooke fgh still computer still
giving black a half half porn of an
advantage simply because from a
structured point of view I'm better the
question is if if this got rooked c7 but
I was really scared him and really lost
the threat we should be five now is an
is a very annoying move I can't go Roxy
7 this is stupid after this I'm just
okay of course just one pair of brooks
trade it is enough if you look at this
this is a huge difference I can even
maybe go here and get this look of as
well and then I'm playing against this
bad porn I mean if we just trade to two
minor pieces i'm playing this for win
for ages without any risk he just has
the better the worse upon formation in
regards to the to the pieces this is
also very bad piece but i got irritated
by the seventh-ranked okay thanks for
watching